ian blackford who is her boss at
westminster is now joining us
live as you can see um hello to you it's
good to see you
um what action should be taken
against margaret ferry it's a very
serious situation as you've outlined k
um the timeline that we now know was
that margaret had a test on saturday
um and while waiting on that test
traveled down to westminster
got the test result on monday evening
and then traveled back
so at the end of the day we've all got
to be judged by
our actions and it's very clear that
people i
am the first minister is pretty angry at
what margaret has done this is a huge
error of judgment i was made aware of
this
yesterday and we took action to suspend
the whip from margaret as a
consequence of all of that the timeline
was that
the chief whip was informed on wednesday
but not of the detail we didn't know
that she traveled down having had a test
neither did the house authorities and i
would commend the house authorities
under chief whip from
making sure that we took action
immediately to find out what had
happened the details
became clear over the course of the day
yesterday i think margaret has got to
reflect
on her position as a an mp she knows
that we will be judged by our actions
everyone has had to make enormous
sacrifices as you and i know over the
last few months kay
um what this has meant for each and
every one of us the position of
authority and leadership that
parliamentarians have
and i have to say that and when you have
a breach such as this
it's really important that you take your
own responsibilities
will you let her make her own decision
well i i don't have any powers over here
she's no longer an snp mp the only power
that i do have
is to remove the whip i've done that um
i can't force an mp to resign
but um margaret's a i think an
honourable individual and i think she
will reflect on what she's done
and the impact that this will have on
our constituents and more widely that
you know when we've gone through this
over the course of the last few months
everything that everyone has had to live
through
and there is that responsibility there's
that honor and dignity that you have to
have as a public official
and i think it's pretty clear that
margaret should do the right thing i
can't compel her to do that
but i think she has to reflect on the
circumstances that she's
put herself and other people in and the
risk that she's brought to people
knowingly travelling well she had covert
19.
what on earth was she thinking what was
she thinking
um look there is no excuse i'm not going
to to make any excuse
for her she felt as i understand it that
she
had to do her job that she had to travel
to westminster that was a cross-era
judgment she shouldn't have done that
in these circumstances she should have
stayed at home um
what she has done is really give a very
poor example to the rest of the public
that we're expecting to
observe the rules and the message that
we should all be giving all governments
all political parties
that if we're to keep this virus at bay
if we're to get to a position of safety
that everybody everybody must be the law
everybody must
be the regulations what she did was risk
the health of every single person
on that train when she knew that she was
covered positive
yeah and look this is this is
inexcusable i mean people that may be
vulnerable
um everyone that was at risk of catching
the virus those that would have been
uh vulnerable within the house of common
staff other members of parliament
there is there is no excuse for any of
this and that's why i'm saying that this
has to be
treated with the utmost seriousness
um and i'm glad to see that the house
authorities moved very quickly to see if
there were
any anyone in on the estate any member
of staff any parliamentarian
that could have been vulnerable to this
there was one person that was identified
as being in close proximity and i'm
glad to see that that person has tested
negative but
there is no doubt that margaret through
her actions has put a lot of other
people at risk as a consequence of what
she did
what would you like to see police
scotland do next
well that's a job for them there is a
separation of course of the
responsibilities that police have from
parliamentarians
um and of course police scotland i'm
sure
uh will be in touch with our colleagues
in the met to see what action has to be
taken
and at the same time kay i know that
margaret has referred herself to the
commissioner for parliamentary standards
so she will need to make herself
available and
be able to take any punishment that
either the police or parliamentary
standards
decide to meet out to her how did you
find out
and how did you feel when you heard
i found out yesterday morning i got a
phone call from um
my chief whip to say that he'd had a
meeting with the
house authorities um i wasn't aware of
all the details the timeline at that
point
i was actually just leaving london to
come back up to my constituency
so when i got to scotland in the
afternoon i was presented with the
details of what had happened i had a
conversation with margaret to find out
what had happened and of course we took
action as quickly as we could
um to one to get a statement from
margaret and secondly to
then withdraw the whip from her
how did that conversation go have you
spoken to her
yeah i've spoken to her on a couple of
occasions and she knows
that uh that we're all pretty angry at
what she's done them and it's
gobsmacking what she's done um it is
it's an enormous
error that she has uh taken by doing all
of this k
um i i mean i regret deeply that
margaret's someone that we we know she's
well regarded within the snp group she's
been a very hard working mp
but at the end of the day there is no
excuse for what she's done
she has to live with this and i'm saying
that she has to reflect on what she's
done and she has to do the right thing
in terms of
her own future she has let her
constituents down she's let everybody
down by her actions as someone who is a
leader in public life
and she's undermined the message from
the first minister
who day in day out week in week out
month in month out has had to um
sacrifice as she would put it um in
order for the
for the better good of the whole of the
scottish people and we see her at the
podium
day after day after day and then one of
her
number does this yeah the first minister
has
shown outstanding leadership over the
course of the last few months but it's
not about the first minister it's about
the sacrifices that everybody has to
make
and the fact that people have not been
able to go about their lives as normal
the fact that people haven't been able
to see their loved ones
and at the end of the day people are
going to be rightly shocked and angered
by an mp that has traveled in the
knowledge that they were at risk of
covered
and then traveled back to scotland
knowing that they
were someone that was suffering from
covert it's not acceptable when it is
important that we demonstrate that
everybody
absolutely everybody must observe the
regulations and certainly must observe
the law and it's on that basis that
margaret has to reflect on our position